what are some other ways i can change
your shape but it still
stays the same morgan to rotate it oh
rotation okay now
i'm going to make that this last one
down here if yours is a different one
i'll come to it next if that's okay
right
so rotation i'm going to stick that down
here
rotation right so again coming back to
my rectangle right
that's right here i'll come back to your
idea if it's another one
okay the idea is it's something like
this isn't it
okay so can someone give me a synonym
for rotation
turn turn's a good one can someone give
me another one why is rotation at the
bottom
uh you'll see why surely okay okay yep
twist twist yep spin
so there you go these are all words that
describe the same idea
now i want you to have a think don't
shout it out think about it this time
with our translation in order to know to
say you know give some instructions and
say i want you all to do the same
translation
you need to know some directions and you
need to know some distances right
otherwise you're like i don't know it's
moving somewhere
i don't know where okay now rotation is
the same it needs some ingredients
but what are they hmm
yeah let's see what are your things
um with the trend you're talking about
translation
ah okay all right so an angle
right so there's the first piece good
something else yeah chassis
okay so degrees that would be something
that would be the same as the so maybe
45 degrees
or 90 or 360 or something like that so
that would come under the angle
is there another piece of information i
need yeah
huh okay i suppose
we could put that in here because um
so is right or left for direction yeah
we would not say that it's a spinning
direction
is it right yeah that's right
okay and we need like a i suppose rather
than write all that you'd say
clockwise or anti-clockwise
right because um 45 degrees one way is
not the same as 45 degrees the other
okay but there's still something else
let me show you what i mean
okay suppose i told you to rotate this
okay um and we said okay maybe we agreed
upon
um 90 degrees in the clockwise direction
90 degrees
okay now if i hold my finger here
hold my finger there okay on this corner
down here in the bottom
right if i rotate 90 degrees clockwise
where will it go
it'll go here right
let me go back let's just draw that in
so you can see what's going on
why didn't you choose that in particular
yes good question
hold on let's talk about that in a
second right so i'm starting from this
corner
right and when i rotate it what happens
you end up with this
is that okay see that is that all right
yes yes
90 degrees clockwise all good right ah
but who asked that question about the
corner dick
i could pick another corner couldn't i i
don't have to go from that corner for
instance i could go from this top corner
right what would happen if i rotated
from there
same thing would it be the same thing i
think it would look like this
isn't that 90 degree it's gone up here
well it's the same shape but it's it's
clearly in a different spot
isn't it yeah right so picking the
corner
or even i don't even have to pick a
corner i don't have to pick a corner do
i
can't i do it like there i could do it
there right in the middle
couldn't i and i would get another shape
again i would get this one
something like that so what's my point
i've i've done the same angle and
direction all three times i need
something else yes huh
okay i need he's here's the word that we
need right
i need a point i need a point you see
the difference between all of these was
if you start from this corner
or this corner or this point in the
middle
yes you end up in a completely different
spot right even with the same angle and
direction
okay so you need to say okay
where are you rotating and this is an
important phrase you want to get
you have to rotate about a certain point
right so i was rotating about here
and then here and then here and i got
different shapes every time okay
draw another letter r
okay now here's what i'm gonna do to
make sure
that we all do the same rotation
the point that i'm going to pick is
going to be
here the end of the um the bottom part
of the arm
okay the bottom right corner if you like
let's all rotate it this same
90 degrees around okay clockwise so it
should end up
let's see
horizontally yes
okay i think that's what you're going to
get is that okay
you might like to put for yourself that
what we've done here is
going this way 90 degrees clockwise
okay